maintenant y at il des signes de bulle
immobilière qui pourraient éclater dans
certaines villes en tout cas la société
canadienne d'hypothèques et de logement
parle de surchauffe de certains marchés
dans pas moins de sept villes comme
toronto par exemple prix des maisons
serait surévalué
alors que dans sept autres régions comme
calgary on aurait trop construit ce qui
provoque des pressions à la baisse sur
le prix des résidences fallait qu'on
voit bien que quand vient le temps
d'acheter une maison les canadiens
disons le ne sont pas tous égaux dans le
pays ou que l'on sait lead en fait ça
dépend de l'argent et de l'endroit par
exemple vous pourriez acheter une belle
maison cossue là avec peut-être cinq six
chambres comme celle ci un peu moins
d'argent baisse cette maison coquette
encore un peu moins d'argent pourquoi
pas une maison de ville ou encore cette
petite maison d'apparence modeste dans
lequel on pourrait mettre plus de
rénovation évidemment ça dépend de
l'endroit où ils achètent par exemple
celle ci c'est winnipeg halifax toronto
vancouver
à votre avis laquelle est la plus chère
à 30 ans toronto mais en fait c'est tout
le même prix pour la modique somme de
900 1999 mille dollars
même cette petite maison sans couverts
maison les vitrines alliés potentiels
comme on dit là il faut y croire malgré
tout ce qui fait dire à la schl dans le
fond qu'il ya énormément de différences
d'une région à l'autre et c'est pour ça
que dans certains coins
elle parle en fait de surchauffe
immobilière par exemple calgary
saskatoon regina
on a trop construit on espérait beaucoup
du boom pétrolier est pour l'instant ce
en train de tomber
c'est très sérieux surévalué à toronto
par contre il faudra également
surveiller québec montréal ottawa où là
il ya des petits signes de craquements
au niveau des prix que ce soit pour les
acheteurs ou pour les vendeurs ils
vancouver dans tout ça qui n'apparaît
pas mais justement à vancouver un autre
exemple du prix exorbitant de la vie
là-bas en fait garder une maison moyenne
2 millions six cent quatre-vingt mille
dollars c'est quand même
énorme évidemment mais par contre on ne
parle pas ici de surévaluation selon la
schl de façon démesurée
par contre quand on la compare à
vancouver avec les autres villes
internationales où les prix sont
surévalués
mais on est quand même 4e derrière
londres mais devant san francisco donc
on le voit c'est quand même assez
incroyable et ça va pas s'arrêter comme
ça mais parce que justement d'abord le
climat très intéressant le monde veut
vivre là il ya toute l'immigration
asiatique a beaucoup d'argent qui
s'installent là et puis surtout pas
écouter on les terrains là on peut pas
en inventer la simple il ya sur place
donc ça veut dire qu' énormément de
pression sur les prix une maison d'un
million de dollars aujourd'hui c'est
peut-être 90 mille 5000 $ le reste c'est
tout le prix du terrain incroyable
intonow vous voyez vous venez d'arriver
vous venez de déménager de vancouver
comme il fait bon vivre à morieux merci
frédéric